[Music]
foreign
a few days back we did a couple of
videos on movie C monsters that are the
size of the Megalodon and another one
that are bigger than Megalodon shark so
the movie versions so here in this one
we will compare and showcase the real
life extinct and present day sea
creatures that are similar in size to a
real-life Megalodon and those that are
larger remember that the real life
estimates for a Meg is between 15 and 20
meters long which translates to
somewhere between 50 to 65 feet and a
weight of somewhere in the range of 50
to 100 tons with a median of 60 to 70
tons so let's get to it
so the first one the humpback whale this
is a baleen whale known for its
distinctive features a bulky body with a
thin Rostrum with long flippers about
one third of its length and a very short
dorsal fin adults range from 14 to 17
meters around 46 to 56 feet in length
and can weigh up to 40 metric tons
notably it has bumps or tubacles on its
head and flippers and its tail fluke has
jacket like trailing edges the dorsal
side is typically black while the
ventral side shows are varying levels of
black and white coloration often more
white in the southern Parts the humpback
whales are found worldwide except for
some areas and equator and the high
Arctic and some enclosed Seas
number two the lead Sixers this is an
extinct Genius of Becky Comet fish from
the middle to the late Jurassic holding
the title of the largest Ray Fin fish
ever found over 70 individuals
fossilized ones have been discovered but
most are incomplete making identifying
and reconstructing the fish its original
form challenging the head was slightly
large white and elongated but with an
unknown snout type Jaws lack teeth and
there was a sturdy part that was present
behind the jaw joints estimates suggest
that the largest specimen measuring
around 17 meters or 56 feet long would
have weighed approximately 45 tons like
the largest fish today it derives its
nutrition as a suspension feeder
number three the mosasaurus the
mosasaurus hoffmani the defining example
of mosasaurs ancient aquatic squamous
reptiles that existed approximately 82
to 66 million years ago during the late
Cretaceous were discovered in the late
18th century their fossils were thought
to be from crocodiles or whales
initially they were later identified as
giant Marine lizards with traits unlike
any known animal the largest species the
mosasaurus of money possibly reached
lengths of around 17.1 meters or 56 feet
in length it propelled itself with its
tail underwater utilizing a swimming
style seen in modern mackerel sharks
elongated battle-like limbs also serve
for maneuvering and the modified joins
allow for Effective flipper rotations
number four the livitan melvley the
Leviton is an extinct macro Raptor of
sperm whale featuring the species El
malvale its name draws from the biblical
leviathan and Hermann mevel the Moby
Dick Author fossils originate around 9.9
to 8.9 million years ago with scalloped
teeth suggesting a global presence until
about 5 million years ago the Leviton
was a dominant Predator likely targeting
whales and seals and even sharks it
boasted functional enamel coated Deeds
on both Jaws tailored for hunting large
prey its size rivaled that of modern
sperm whales estimated at 13.5 to 17.5
meters or 44 to 57 feet long it may have
interacted with the Megalodon and face
Extinction due to a cooling event at the
myosin's end affecting food sources
fossils found alongside it prove
insights to a diverse range worldwide
number five the symbol spoilers the
symbol spoilers an early exosaur from
the Triassic period 249 to 237 million
years ago featured a basal design it was
initially categorized as a Shasta Sauron
but later research places it as being
more primitive with an elongated
cylindrical body unlike later species it
achieved medium to large sizes with some
species reaching immense proportions its
wedge-shaped skull tapered evenly
towards a snout tip primarily composed
of the premaxular and nasal bones
flipping the skull vertically you will
likely see it look like a funnel notably
the largest species the symbol spondylus
young grow room potentially grew to up
to 17.7 meters or 58 feet in length and
weighing around 44.7 metric tons
number six the bowhead whale the bowhead
whale is a baleen whale in the balanide
family and a sole surviving member of
the bolani genus it is unique among Bali
in Wales found only in the Arctic and
sub-arctic Waters its distinct massive
triangular skull AIDS it in Breaking the
Arctic eyes with the largest mouth of
any animal nearly a third of its body
length measuring up to 4 meters or 13
feet they are very exceptional feeders
they might be the longest lived animals
as well exceeding over 200 years in age
comparable in size to some right whale
species they can reach lengths of up to
18 meters or 60 feet or even larger
number seven the paracetus Colossus the
paracetus is an extinct early wheel
discovered in Peru from the iosin epoch
estimated to measure over 17 to 20
meters or 56 to 66 feet long and
weighing between 85 to 3 and 40 tons it
could have rival or even surpassed a
modern blue whale in weight its immense
size was due to exceptionally dense
Bones the paracetus lifestyle is still a
mystery though its fossil suggests it
inhabited slow-moving shallow Waters
while its exact diet is uncertain it
might have consumed bottom-dwelling
creatures like Crustaceans and mollus
number 8 the basilosaurus the
basilosaurus which translates to King
Lizard is actually a genus of imposing
predatory ancient whales that existed
during the late eocene around 41 to 33
million years ago this genus includes
two species the basilosaurus cetiris and
basilosaurus Isis both of which went
extinct by the clothes of the eosine
epoch possibly due to a significant
planetary event the basilosaurus held
dominance in the oceans during its time
and their sizes could have reached
around 21 meters or 69 feet in length
notably the basilosaurus whales
exhibited a sleeker physique than many
modern counterparts resembling elongated
eels on a grand scale they possess small
hind limbs though towards the back of
their bodies likely aiding in just
mating foreign
this was a unique specimen among
ichthyosaurs having a slender profile
and a very distinctive shot toothless
now while it was suggested that it may
have been a suction feeder recent
studies challenged this notion ancest
otherwise the presence of its dorsal fin
is uncertain unlike more primitive
idiosaurs it likely had a less developed
up of tail flu compared to later species
which means it was less maneuverable and
swam at a slower speed it lived in the
late Triassic period with a species
shastasaurus psychonensis from British
Columbia's formation lived around 210
million years ago reaching an impressive
length of up to 21 meters or 69 feet and
weighing 81.5 metric tons
number 10 the sperm whale the sperm
whale is the largest of the two set of
whales and the largest Predator ever it
is The Only Living member of the genus
faisetta and one of three extant species
in a sperm whale family including the
pygmy sperm whales the sperm whale is a
pelagic mammal with a worldwide range
and will migrate seasonally for feeding
and breeding males mature at about 15 to
16 meters long or 49-52 feet in length
but larger ones can generally achieve 18
to 19 meters or 59 to 62 feet and there
was a 24 meter or 79 feet male measured
from the South Pacific in 1933 and this
was the largest recorded number 11 the
fin back whale also called the finback
or the common rock roll this is a baleen
whale species it is the second longest
cetacean globally trailing only after
the blue whale the largest individuals
reached a length of about 27.3 meters or
around 90 feet with a confirmed maximum
of many of them being around 20 6 meters
or 85 feet an estimate to weigh around
114 tons they are colored brownish gray
with a paler Underside the fin whale has
a long slender body and inhabits all
major oceans from The Polar to the
tropical waters excluding areas near the
polar ice pack and certain smaller water
zones
and number 12 the blue whale the blue
whale is a marine mammal and also baleen
whale reaching a maximum confirmed
length of 29.9 meters or 98 feet and
weigh up to 199 tons it is the largest
animal known ever to have existed though
there could be a rival in the paracetus
for the wage glass recent studies
suggest a blue whale could never exceed
108 feet or 33 meters because of
metabolic and energy constraints
although they are very large their diet
consists of almost exclusively of near
microscopic Grill and they capture Krill
through lunch feeding swimming towards
the Krill at very high speeds as they
open their mouths up to 80 degrees
so those are the many creatures living
and extinct that are around the size of
the megalodon or even larger anyway I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
and new videos here on this channel take
care fam